LAWLESSNESS TO TRY TO ONE UP
HIM.
HERE IS MARK FUHRMAN AND JOHN
YOO.
MARK THIS HAS ALWAYS BEEN A
TROUBLE SPOT FOR THE DEMOCRATS
AS A PARTY.
WHY ARE THEY INCREASINGLY
TURNING THEIR FRUSTRATION AND
UPSET TO ALL LAW ENFORCEMENT,
NOT JUST A FEW BAD APPLES BUT TO
ALL OF LAW ENFORCEMENT?
>> WELL, LAURA, WHEN YOU LOOK AT
IT, THEY ARE TRYING TO ATTRACT
THAT BASE, THAT 18 TO
25-YEAR-OLD BASE THAT IS
INVOLVED IN ALL OF THESE
MOVEMENTS.
THESE ANTI-GOVERNMENT,
ANTI-REPUBLICAN AND ANTI-TRUMP.
THEY ARE TRYING TO ATTRACT THAT
GROUP OF PEOPLE AND THE POLICE.
IT'S VERY EASY TO ATTACK THEM
BECAUSE THEY DON'T RESPOND TO A
CALL OR ANY CRIME OF VIOLENCE
AND WONDER IF SOMEBODY IS A
LIBERAL OR A CONSERVATIVE, A
DEMOCRAT OR A REPUBLICAN.
THEY RESPOND AND DO WHAT IS
APPROPRIATE AT THAT TIME FOR
WHOEVER.
THEY CAN DO ANYTHING THEY WANT
AND I KNOW THE POLICE WILL STILL
DO THEIR JOBS.
WHEN YOU PICK OUT CASES THEY
KNOW THAT THE POLICE DID NOTHING
WRONG AND THAT THE PERSON THAT
DIED OR WAS INJURED CONTRIBUTEED
TO HIS OWN SITUATION, THEY NEVER
CALL THAT PERSON ON HIS
RESPONSIBILITY TO CONDUCT
HIMSELF A CERTAIN WAY.
THEY WIN ALL THE WAY AROUND.
>> Laura: AND JOHN, IT'S
FASHIONABLE TO PUSH FOR THE
RELEASE OF CRIMINALS.
THERE IS A MERCYFUL ASPECT TO
THIS.
WHEN YOU ARE A PARTY ATTACKING
PRO-LAW ENFORCEMENT EXPERIENCES
OF SOME OF YOUR CANDIDATES,
THAT'S THE NEGATIVE THING.
IF YOU WERE TOUGH ON CRIME, YOU
CAN'T BE IN THIS PARTY ALMOST.
THAT'S A WILD PLACE TO BE.
SO THEY WENT AFTER BOOKER AND
THIS WAS A BIT ON KAMALA
HARRIS'S RECORD.
>> SENATOR HARRIS IS PROUD OF
HER RECORD AS A PROSECUTOR.
SHE PUT OVER 1500 PEOPLE IN JAIL
FOR MARIJUANA VIOLATIONS AND
LAUGHED ABOUT IT IF WHEN ASKED
IF SHE SMOKED MARIJUANA.
>> I AM PROUD OF DOING THE WORK.
>> THE PEOPLE WHO SUFFERED UNDER
YOUR REIN AS PROSECUTOR YOU OWE
THEM AN APOLOGY.
>> Laura: IT'S NOT THE VICTIMS
OF CRIME SUFFERING.
IT'S THE PEOPLE PUT BEHIND BARS.
>> I WISH PEOPLE LIKE HARRIS OR
BOOKER WOULD BE TO DEFEND THE
POLICE AND THE PROSECUTORS AND
THE RECORD OF SUCCESS HAPPENING
IN THIS COUNTRY FOR THE LAST 25
YEARS.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY SAYS THEY
ARE THE PARTY OF FACTS.
IN THE LAST 25 YEARS VIOLENT
CRIME DROPPED 50% AND PROPERTY
CRIMES BY 70%.
THEY SHOULD BE PROUD OF THAT
RECORD OF SUCCESS.
THAT'S NOT JUST ELECTED
POLITICIANS, THAT'S POLICE AND
PROSECUTORS AND JUDGES.
INSTEAD YOU HEAR ELIZABETH
WARREN SAYING THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM IS RACIST FROM
FRONT TO BACK AND BLAMING THE
POLICE.
THEY SHOULD BE PROUD THEY
DROPPED CRIME RATES AT SUCH
ENORMOUS LEVELS FOR 25 YEARS.
THIS IS NOTHING LIKE IT IN
AMERICAN HISTORY.
>> Laura: WE HAVE A BIG PROBLEM
IN CERTAIN AMERICAN CITIES IN
SURROUNDING AREAS OF RECRUITMENT
OF POLICE.
WE ARE HAVING A DIFFICULT TIME
GETTING PEOPLE TO TAKE THE CIVIL
SERVICE EXAM IN SOME DISTRICTS.
IS THAT WHAT THEY WANT?
TO MAKE IT SUCH AN UNPOPULAR
CAREER CHOICE THAT YOUNG MEN AND
WOMEN DECIDE IT'S NOT WORTHY?
THEN WHERE WILL WE BE?
>> THEY WANT A POLICE FORCE THAT
IS MADE UP OF PEOPLE THAT REALLY
DON'T HAVE THE PRIDE FOR WHAT
THEY ARE ACTUALLY CHOSEN AS A
PROFESSION.
THEY GO ALONG TO GET ALONG.
THE PROBLEM IS WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT LISTENING TO POLITICIANS
THAT ARE TRYING TO BE ELECTED.
YOU CAN'T TRUST A THING THEY
SAY.
YOU CAN BARELY TRUST ANY
POLITICIAN ANY TIME TO BELIEVE
WHAT THEY SAY.
HERE WE ARE TRYING TO FORM OUR
WHOLE LAW ENFORCEMENT ATTITUDE
ACROSS THE NATION BECAUSE OF 22
PEOPLE THAT ARE RUNNING FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC NOMINATION.
THAT'S ABSURD.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS, THEY HAD
AMPLE OPPORTUNITIES MANY TIMES
UNDER BARACK OBAMA AND HOLDER TO
HOLD OFF OFFICERS RESPONSIBLE
CRIMINALLY WHERE THERE WAS
RACIAL OVERTONES.
FERGUSON AND A FEW OTHER PLACES
AND THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT FOUND
NO VIOLATION.
WE HAD GRAND JURIES THAT FOUND
THAT'S NOT THE PLATFORM THAT
CARRIES THESE PEOPLE.
>> Laura: THE PEOPLE WERE STILL
THROWN AROUND IN THE DEBATE.
OFFICER WILSON CAN NEVER WORK
AGAIN AS A POLICE OFFICER.
HIS NAME WAS DRAGGED THROUGH THE
MUD AFTER FERGUSON.
I THINK HE HAD TO CHANGE HIS
NAME.
HE WON'T GIVE AN INTERVIEW.
HE WAS ACCUSED OF MURDERING
SOMEONE IN COLD BLOOD.
THAT'S NOT WHAT THE FINDINGS
WERE.
THAT WAS IRRESPONSIBLE.
JOHN, I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT
WHAT HARRIS SAID ABOUT --
ACTUALLY CASTRO SAID AT THE
DEBATE ABOUT A NATIONAL USE OF
FORCE STANFORD.
FEDERALIZING THE POLICE USE OF
FORCE.
>> WHETHER IT'S THE CASE OF
SOMEONE LIKE RICE OR MICHAEL
BROWN OR ERIC GARNER WHERE THE
TRUMP JUSTICE DEPARTMENT DECIDED
NOT TO PURSUE CHARGES.
WE NEED TO END IMMUNITY FOR
POLICE OFFICERS TO HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE.
>> Laura: JOHN.
FEDERALIZING USE OF FORCE
STANDARDS?
>> I AM GLAD YOU PLAYED THAT
CLIP.
THAT'S UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
THIS IS AN AREA WHERE THE
CONSTITUTION ITSELF PLACES
LIMITS ON POLICE AT EVERY LEVEL
OF JURISDICTION, CITY, STATE AND
LOCAL.
IT'S NOT THE JOB OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
THAT'S UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
IT'S A SOUND BITE LOOKING FOR A
PROBLEM.
THE STATISTICS SHOW NO RACIAL
DIFFERENCE IN THE USE OF FORCE
AND POLICE SHOOTINGS IN THE
COUNTRY.
>> Laura: I KNOW NO ONE BELIEVES
THAT.
THE LEFT WILL KEEP SPREADING
LIVES.
MARK, THE DECISION TONIGHT WHERE
NYPD SUSPENDED THE POLICE
OFFICER INVOLVED IN THE CHOKE
HOLD DEATH OF ERIC GARNER IN
2014.
THE VIDEO LOOKED HORRIFIC.
HE SAID HE COULD NOT BREATHE.
TODAY A JUDGE RECOMMENDED THAT
DANIEL PANTALEO BE FIRED AND
MAYOR BILL DE BLASIO SUPPORTS
IT.
>> UNTIL TODAY THE GARNER FAMILY
HAS BEEN FAILED BY THIS ENTIRE
PROCESS.
AS ALL OF THIS STRETCHED ON, IT
REINFORCES THE SUSPICION THAT
JUSTICE DOESN'T EXIST FOR PEOPLE
WHO LOOK LIKE ERIC GARNER.
>> Laura: AND PAT LYNCH FIRED
BACK.
>> I STAND HERE TODAY TO TELL
EVERY NEW YORK CITY POLICE
OFFICERS AND THEY ARE ON PATROL
RIGHT NOW, WHEN SOMEONE CALLS
9-11 AND DISPATCHERS CALL YOU
AND IN THE SWHERE YOU HAVE TO
PUT YOUR HANDS ON SOMEONE, CALL
YOUR SERGEANT FIRST AND CALL
EMERGENCY SERVICE SECOND.
BECAUSE YOU WILL NOT HAVE THE
BACKING OF THE CITY!
>> Laura: STRONG WORDS.
YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> WELL, WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
ERIC GARNER CASE, IT WASN'T A
HORRIFIC ALTERCATION.
IT WAS A SLOW KIND OF
RESISTANCE.
HIS SIZE COMPLICATED EVERYTHING.
HE DIDN'T APPLY A CHOKE HOLD.
HE HAD A TAKE DOWN HOLD AND HE
IMMEDIATELY REMOVED HIS ARM.
HIS PHYSICAL CONDITION AND THE
SITUATION MIGHT HAVE CAUSED HIS
DEATH.
WE DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T THINK IT WAS CONCLUSIVE.
YOU HAVE THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND ERIC HOLDER WHO HAS THIS
CASE FOR 2 YEARS AND CAN'T MAKE
THE MOVEMENT ON IT.
THE GRAND JURY CLEARED HIM.
SAYING THERE WAS NOT ENOUGH
EVIDENCE FOR A VIOLATION THAT
TAKES INTENT.
NOT JUST SOMEBODY THAT CREATES
HIS OWN ALTERCATION AND RENDERS
HIMSELF DEAD.
THIS IS NOT A SITUATION WHERE
THERE SHOULD BE AN INDICTMENT.
BECAUSE OF PUBLIC OPINION THAT
THE DEMOCRATS WANT, THEY WILL
PROBABLY FIRE THIS OFFICER.